[MUSIC PLAYING]
SAMI KIZILBASH: So at
Google Play, we love games.
We want games to be engaging.
We want game developers
to be successful.
VINEET TANWAR: We put
them through a Boot Camp
and they get feedback from
leading industry experts,
mentors, and they continue to
receive support long after they
graduate from the program.
ANURAG RANA: The moment
when we were selected,
we're just scrolling through
all the names and saying,
where's our name?
Where's our name?
And suddenly the name came
up, both of us, we got up,
we ran to the edge of the
room then came back and gave
each other a huge high-five.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
KEERTI SINGH: I think
it's going to be super
awesome, considering all the
people from the gaming industry
would be there.
There's a lot in store
for all the developers
to learn over here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SAMI KIZILBASH: Welcome to Indie
Games Accelerator, everybody.
[CHEERS]
DESMOND WONG: It's also
been really, really great.
We've learned so much
from all the mentors, even
our fellow game developers and
Indies from around this region.
RAMI ISMAIL: One of
my favorite things
was just the variety of problems
and issues and opportunities
that we get to deal
with and help on.
ALOK KEJRIWAL: If you've gained
so much from this industry
and from the people
who helped us,
it's time to give
it back to them.
HOWARD GO: The best thing in
the program were the mentors.
I think mentors who knew
the business better than us,
who were able to state
hard truths that allowed
us to change our perspective.
ASFANDIYAR KHAN: The Indie
Games Accelerator Program
has given me the confidence
that we can really
make amazing games.
It doesn't matter where
you are in the world.
And my friends and
family are definitely
taking me more seriously and
what I do more seriously.
SAMI KIZILBASH: 2019, I'm
super excited about seeing
what these Indies come out
with, the new titles, but also
the teams that they
developed over time.
I'm also excited about bringing
in a whole new batch of Indies,
helping them through the
process of launching new titles
and building their game
studios and seeing what we can
do with them on a global stage.
[MUSIC PLAYING]